jacqueline woodson she is a New York
Times bestselling author with more than
five million copies of her work sold
worldwide
her memoir brown girl dreaming won the
National Book Award that was back in
2014 more than two dozen children's
books are regularly taught in schools
all around the country
so her newest work of adult fiction is
called read at the bone it tells the
story of how to Brooklyn families cope
after an unexpected pregnancy bring them
to get brings them together Jacqueline
Woodson joins us at the table welcome
Bravo to you you were getting rave
reviews I love it when when a review
uses the word dazzling yeah when I see
that I did - I did - so read at the bone
means what it has a special meaning so
when I was thinking about that title I
was thinking about the way we are all
sort of still in development still
cooking in a way so in that particular
scene where the title gets unveiled iris
one of the main characters has just had
her heart broken and she feels raw she
feels undone yeah and I think in terms
of the human condition we all feel that
at some point we're already at the bone
we were talking earlier about writing
against stereotyping here's what's
interesting about this book is we're
very familiar with stories where the man
the father walks away and disappears and
now we have a mother on a bit of a
wander I can't with that to say the
least ya know as a mom as a person who
had a mom I have a deep respect for
motherhood and that sense of what's at
stake and and you know some days we want
to walk away you know we don't want to
not come back but when I was developing
the character of iris I asked myself the
question what does it mean to be a
mother who has a child very young and at
one point she says in the book you know
I was only 15 I wasn't even anything yet
and I think to grow up and realize you
have different ideas of how you want to
live your life and making those choices
is very hard but as the author I had to
have empathy for her to show that she
wasn't a bad person that yeah but
wanting to have her own life and she
wasn't in love with the father - she
said I didn't want to spend the rest of
my life with him I want to have his baby
but I didn't want to spend the rest of
my like my life with him and it's also
what I like is a historical drama that
you brought into it
yes that scene that the Tulsa riots that
I think most people I hadn't heard of it
world many years I heard of it maybe 10
15 years ago but the way you
incorporated that into the story I think
is is really very appreciative yeah what
made you want to bring that in it took
place in 1921 in Tulsa yes it was known
as the Tulsa Race Massacre and it was a
very established black community that
was destroyed by white people who there
were black professionals yes there were
hairdressers and lawyers and doctors and
bankers they had their own bank they had
their beauty parlors and barber shop
driving commercial - yeah and
residential community and and it got
destroyed and so with it went all of
this black wealth and this black
middle-class population just got you
know they were murdered they were
murdered from the air the official
Commission there in Oklahoma says that
Tulsa was likely the first city in the
United States to be bombed from the air
white men and airplanes dropping
kerosene bombs yes true story that most
of us don't know about why is that I
didn't know about it until I was in my
20s it's not taught in schools you know
so I think the way we remember history
is by having it repeated and having it
taught and I had no idea that this had
happened well that's the beauty of how
you tell the story because you go back
and forth in time between the characters
through their lives so you take us on a
history lesson too while you're also
developing the rapport between all the
characters in the book it's a different
kind of writing style that you use this
time yeah I was trying to represent it
the way life is I mean we don't start at
the beginning right we ever we're part
of a continuum and so it opens with but
that but that afternoon an orchestra was
playing so we are walking right into the
middle of this narrative and I and I go
back and forth and time to represent
that you know people don't just meet one
day and fall in love it's looking back
at their own histories and I think they
were there is yeah I wanted to ask you
about the young people's literature
rhetoric what is the one
you are the national ambassador for
young people's literature you've been
talking to kids all around the country
what is the message that you deliver to
them my look what I say is reading
equals hope times change and and I do
believe that when we read it gives us
hope and it changes us we're different
when we start a book and when we finish
it that is so true times change
thank you very much I was like this is
why we today